오늘은 제 비사남미 간다. 근처를 한
번도 안 했어요. 네. 가로 앞에
여러분들이 잘 알고 있던 프리마
호텔을 이제 신축하려고 준비 중인데
원래 저게 그 PF 연장이 안
됐었어요. 어 고급 호텔이 또
들어옵니다. 부동산 호환기 때 그때
이제 매입을 해 가지고 명도하는데
시간이 좀 많이 소요가 됐어요.
그러면서 좀 금리가 갑자기 오르기
시작했고 상황이 매우 안
좋아졌거든요. 전 아도 기억에 남는게
여기 지하에 그 유흥업소가
있었거든요. 집행하시는 분들이 진짜
몇십 명이 와 가지고 이렇게 용도를
하고 계시더라고요. 그리고 지금
이쪽에 보면은이 루시아 오피스텔 어
최근에 이제 올렸는데
저것도 이제 뭐 아파트인데 막
100억이 다 넘어가게 이제 분양을
했는데 개인적으로는 그 물론 뭐 몇
개나 분양됐는지는 정확히는 모르겠지만
그 땅의 면적이 그렇게 크진
않습니다. 200평 한 중후반 정도로
된 걸로 기억하는데 위치가 되게
괜찮아서 상부층부터는이
한강뷰가 되게 잘 나와요. 어,
일단은 여기 청단공원 블록 같은
경우에는 공원도 있고 아침에 맨날
여기 산책하거든요. 네. 그러면서
여기 이제 고급 주택들이 많이
밀집되어 있고 어, 여기는 따로 뭐
상권이나 그런 건 없어요. 네.
대부분 그냥 이제 다 주거나 아니면
오피스 조금 있는 정도. 예. 그
정도라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
접근하기에는 저기 PM스 에가 제일
좋아요. 거기가 땅면적도 되게
적당하고 어 빌딩 투자하기는 되게
좋은 블록이라고 생각합니다.
그리고 아까 말씀드렸던 저기 프리마
호텔이 올라가면 그이면 쪽으로도 조금
영향이 있을 거라고 생각은 하거든요.
그래서 보통 이제 호텔 투수객분들이
거기 인근을
이용을 좀 많이 합니다. 네. 그
장기적으로는 그 뭐 이쪽 블록도 뭐
투자 가치가 괜찮다라고 생각은 하지만
아직 시간이 굉장히 좀 많이
남았습니다. 청남동 아파트 투자는
그어요? 어 청남 아파트 너무
좋죠?네 네. 아파트 너무 좋고.
근데 이제 아파트 그 보통 여기가
이제 고급 빌라가 되게 많은데
고급빌라의 일단 단점은
매각이 잘 안 됩니다. 뭐 세대수도
워낙 없기 때문에 시세도 정확히 알
수가 없어요. 그래서 아까 저희 회사
옆집이 그 최근에 그 서현진 씨
전세사기 났던 어 그 빌라인데 그
빌라도 그 서현진 씨가 이제 25억에
들어왔다가 뭐 26억 정도까지 증액해
가지고 전세금을 못 돌려받았는데 지금
경매가 나왔는데 계속 유찰되고
있어요. 네. 그래서 이런 빌라들은
정확한 시세를 파악하기가 쉽지
않습니다.
그래서 만약에 뭐 청담동에 빌라를
산다라고 하면은 정말 그냥 실거주
목적으로 어 계획을
하시면 어 뭐 투자해도 괜찮지만
청남동에 그냥 아파트에 투자를
한다라고 하면은 어 이런 좀 세대수
많은 어 그런 아파트가 괜찮은 거
같고 저 개인적으로 차라리 여기가
괜찮은 거 같아요. 여기 그 라클래시
아파트 있는 요쪽 요쪽 블로
힐스테이트 요런 데가 살기는 되게
좋은 거 같고 저는 강남구청 역
쪽에서 지금 합동 사거리 쪽으로 가고
있습니다. 이제
강남구 쪽에서 거래가 제일 활발한
것이 어디인까요? 강남구에서 제일
거래 많은 데는 사실 뭐 청담은
아니고요. 청담 아니고 대부분 다
무슨 노년이나 역삼 쪽에 거래가 좀
많이 있는 거 같아요. 앞구정은
어떤가요? 앞구정은 사실 아파트밖에
없죠. 그래서 여기도 보면은어야
이러고 저기 장근석시 건물 있고
그래서 여기 1번지 자들 아시죠?
1번지가
이슈가 많이 됐어요. 그래서 예전에
조감도가 정말 화려해서 과연 어떤
건물이 들어올지 되게 어 기대를 많이
했는데 어 지금 외관이 이렇게
됐죠.요 건물인가요? 예. 요거 한때
이슈가 많았죠. 어떻게 보면
청담동에서 제일 좋은 땅 중에
하나라고 생각하거든요. 그리고 그
번지수 1번지 어 정말 최고의
자리인데
자주 가졌던 맥도날드가 이제 철거가
됐어요. 그래서 어 매각이 되면서음
지금 신축 준비 중에 있습니다.
1호점은 저쪽에 있었고 일단 여기
드라이브스로 있었는데 그게
철거됐습니다. 그래서 그게 평단가 한
2억 한 중후반 정도의 매각이
됐어요. 그래서 저쪽에 보시면은
어 저기 이제 철거하고 짓고 있죠.
그래서 제가 한 가지 여러분들 보셔야
될 포인트는 거기 위에 광고판 어 저
광고판이 아마 가려질 겁니다. 저기
신축되면 저기 광고판에서 수익이
상당한데 저 광고판 이슈가 좀 있죠.
네. 지금 울프 쪽에 왔는데 다시
PN로스 뒤쪽을 갈게요. 그래서
여러분들이 만약에 청담동에 투자를
하고 싶다라고 하면이 블록은 사기
어려워요.이 블록은 금액대도 되게
높고 처음 접근하기가 쉽지 않습니다.
이쪽이 이제 삼성물산에서 가지고 있는
건물인데 예전에 이제 저 일대를 평당
1억 5천에 다 매입했거든요. 근데
그때 당시에는 가격이 되게 비쌌었는데
어 거기 일대를 다 매입해 가지고
이렇게 지은 겁니다. 제가 뭐 얼핏
들었는데 벤츠도 이제 내년부터
인터넷으로 막 판매한다라고 합니다.
네. 그래서 지금 테슬라가 인터넷으로
판매를 하는데 어 되게 상당히 그래도
뭐 문제 없이 잘 되잖아요. 여기가
이제 상업지 비율이 되게 높아요.
네. 노선 상업지인데 그래서 건물을
올리면 지금 보시면은 한 3,
4층짜리 건물이지만 거의 800%
가까이 봤습니다. 네. 그래서 땅이
되게 좋아요. 그래서 여기 여기 블록
있죠? 여기 요쪽 요쪽 이면에 보면은
여기 원래 청담동 달동네였거든요.
저희도 여기 임대해 보면 생각보다
되게 잘됩니다. 그래서 여기 임차인
구석 보시면은 지하에는 뭐 이렇게시집
있는 거 같고 뭐 한복나라 그다음에
이제 뭐 오피스 쓰고 있고 그 임대
컨디션이
그래도 뭐 다른 그냥 애매한
오피스보다는
괜찮은 거 같아요. 요쪽 블록도 한번
검토해 보시면 좋을 거 같고 돼지
면적이 그렇게 크지 않아요. 보통 한
5, 60평뭐 70평 대가 많아서 어
접근하기에는 되게 현실적인
어 그런 곳이라고 생각을 합니다.
네.
한 손으로 운전해서 좀 버릇도 없어
보이진 않죠. 너무 멋있 섹시해
보입니다.
아니
원래 군대에서 이렇게 했거든. 여기
10시 2시
이렇게 해가지고 이런 걸 좀 넣어.
김정은 씨 건물이 여기 있죠. 그
북한에 계신 분 말고
그 연예인 김정은 씨가요 앞에 있던
건물에 뒤에 있는 건물을 같이 매입해
가지고 이렇게 지은 거예요. 건물을
되게 잘 지었죠.
그래서 청담동 하면은 생각하는 맛집
있을까요? 맛집이요? 저는
개인적으로는
이게 어떤 아 저는 여기 그 송훈빌딩
전에도 한번 말씀드렸었는데
어 송은빌딩 되게 유명한 건축가가
설계했습니다.
헤르저크 드메롱이라고 되게 유명한
건축가가 지었고 건축비만 몇백억든
걸로 알고 있어요. 저 안에 그
신청함에 들어가실 수 있거든요. 되게
좀 신기하게 돼 있습니다. 내부가
그래서 한번 가서 보시면 좋을 거
같고 그리고 여기 좀 가다 보면은
손흥민 선수가 매입한 애트론너 2가
있습니다.
어 장학 건설에서
원래 현대 건설이었는데
이게 땅이 커요. 거의 1천평 정도
됩니다. 1천000평이 넘어요.
그래서 뭐 아까 또 말씀드렸지만 일단
땅이 커야 됩니다. 그래서 그 안에
넣어야 될 것도 되게 많고. 와,
이거 이야.
저렇게 이렇게만 봐도 와, 이거
친구가 엄청
야, 그러니까 지금 에테르노원이 너무
잘 됐거든요. 네.
그래서 이제 엄청 크네요. 부지가
엄청 커요. 에테론는 원보다 더
커요. 아, 진짜 저기 펜트하우스가
되게 가격이 높아요. 그래서 금액을
정확히 말씀드릴 순 없지만 정말
우리나라에서 제일 비싼 가격이라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다. 여기 보면은
요건물이 매각이 됐었거든요. 그래서
여기가 사실 전면이 되게 가래
있었어요. 여기 이제 지하철 출구
때문에. 근데 여기 이제 성형액가가
들어왔습니다.
나나 성형이 되게 잘 들어온 거
같아요.
광고성도 되게 좋고 전에 영상으로도
말씀드렸지만 저는 명품 거리를 되게
좋아합니다. 더 잘 될 거 같고 어
여기는 완전 뭐 한국뿐만 아니라
글로벌한 길이라고 저는 생각을 하고
여기는 뭐 들어올 수도 없어요. 네.
들어올 수도 없고
엄청 로렉스 이거 그거 아닌가요? 이
마이바우 마이바우 있던 거 이제 이만
회장 콘스탄틴 외관 아주 멋있습니다.
바식 커피도 있고
뭐 샤넬 뭐 다 있죠.
외국인 관광객들도 많이 와요. 지금
보면은. 그니까 여기 이제 뭐 명품
업체 기준으로 봤을 땐 사실 백화점에
들어가는 거보다 이렇게 단독 건물로
있는게 되게 메리트가 있어요.
백화점은 사실 고객들이 오기에도 되게
좀 불편하기도 하거든요. 되게
프라이빗한 고객분은 이렇게 좀
노출되는 것도 꺼려하고 그리고 그
안에서 할 수 있는게 한계가 있는데
여기 같은 경우에는 단독 건물을
만약에 쓰게 되면 그 안에서
플래그십도를 할 만한게 되게 많아요.
행사를 한다든지 연예인을 초청해서 뭘
한다라든지 그런 메리트가 되게 많기
때문에 이런 명품 업체들이 당장 안
들어와도 임대 계약부터 일단 합니다.
몇십 년을 해 버려요. 그래서 지금
여기 좌측에도 보시면은 이렇게 안
들어온 거 같잖아요. 뭐이 건물뿐만
아니라 다른 건물도 임대차 계약이
되어 있는 경우가 되게 많습니다.
저는 뭐 명품거리는 배 괜찮다라고
생각하고 그리고 다른 뭐 뉴욕이나 막
이런데 비교했을 때도 임대료가 되게
싸다고 생각하거든요, 저는. 그래서
명품 업체들이 들어올 때도 되게
메리트가 있다라고 저는 생각을
합니다. 그리고 지금 요쪽에
제가 맨날 밥먹 밥 먹으러 오는
블록입니다.
이쪽인데
아 여기 상권은 그 막 크게
좋아지거나 그런 건 없어요. 네.
좋아진 그런 거 없고 예전보다 예전에
이제 여기도 있었고 막 그때는 되게
뭔가 좋았었는데 뭔가 지금 느낌은
조금 침체돼 있는 느낌 뭐 그런
느낌을 저 개인적으로는 좀 받고
있습니다.
그래서 여기 곳곳에
맛집들이 있긴 한데 막 이렇게 외부
사람들이 많이 오는 곳은 아니에요.
말씀드렸던 그런 곳에 있는 쪽.
그쪽은 외부 사람들이 많이 찾아오는
블록이긴 하는데 여기는 상대적으로
그거에 비교해서는 좀 그렇게 크진
않은 거 같고 그리고 여기 안쪽으로
들어가면 다 이런 고급 빌러합니다.
상지 리치빌 멤버스 카운팅 뭐 이쪽이
다 몰려 있고 그래서 여기 보통
연예인분들이 많이 살고 있어요.
청남동에서 가장 좋았던 거물 사례가
있을까요? 일단은 저는 에테르노
부지를 생각보다 그렇게 비싸게
매입하진 않았어요. 그래서 저게 한번
이렇게 공매로 나왔었던 거거든요.
그래서 공매로 나와서 저 땅을 되게
매력적인 가격에 샀었어요. 한 7,
800억 막이 정도에 땅을 사 가지고
저렇게 지은 건데 일단 자리가 너무
좋다 보니까 그리고 이제 어떻게 보면
에테르노가 첫 스타트를 끊었다라고
생각하거든요. 그래서 저렇게 고급
주거를
만드는 처음에 이제 저기 땅 파고
했을 때 그때 당시에 이제 저거 뭐
100억이면 누가 사 막 그랬거든요.
네. 근데 지금 와서 보니까 뭐
100억이 뭐예? 200억 훨씬
넘거든요. 지금 매물도 없어요. 뭔가
상품을 저렇게 잘 만들어 놓으면
저렇게 비싼 가격에도 수요가 있구나.
네. 그런 생각을 좀 많이 했습니다.
그리고 지금 에테르노 옆에 여기 이제
원어 청담 짓고 있거든요. 기사 많이
나왔었잖아요. 이렇게 차 타고 이렇게
올라가는. 저는 개인적으로는
에테르노가 좀 전면도 더 넓고 땅도
그렇고 활용도가 좀 더 좋지 않나
이제 개인적인 생각입니다. 그리고
여기 이제 건형 아파트 리모델링
하려고 좀 미중에 있고 에테르노 진짜
잘 기획해 가지고 만든 거
같습니다.데 제가 오늘 좀 이렇게
가볍게 어 드라이브스를 촬영을 했는데
어 이게 괜찮다라고 뭐 댓글 좀 남겨
주시거나 아니면이 지역을 좀 해
주셨으면 좋겠습니다 하면은 제가
이렇게 차 타고 이동하면서 편하게
많은 정보들을 좀 압축해서 어
여러분들한테 알려 드리도록
하겠습니다. 그래서 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요. 필딩은 역시
필산함.
[음악]